نعم مره اخرى ميسون بعد وجبه الافطار التي
كانت هنا في المسجد الحرام وتناولها
الجميع من المعتمرين وكذلك الزوار ونحن
ايضا نتواجد على سطح المسجد الحرام على
ارتفاع يبلغ 20 متر او عشرين متر عن صحن
المطاف ما زلت عمليه التنظيم من قبل
القوات امن الحج والعمره وكذلك قوه الامن
وقوات الدعم والاسناد من الجهات الامنيه
الاخرى تقوم بعمليه تنظيم المعتمرين ودخول
الزوار الى المسجد الحرام
حركه سلسه وكذلك رغم الكثافه العدديه الا
ان العمليه كما تشاهدها وترصدها كاميرا
العربيه من على ارتفاع
وتحديدا على الحراميه
جدا نعم وهذه صور خاصه للعربيه تنقل الان
في هذه اللحظات بعد ان تناولوا المعتمرين
والزوار وجبه الافطار وادوا صلاه المغرب
وهم الان يستكمل المعتمرين ايضا طوافيهم
في حركه سلسه ونشاهد ايضا هناك بعض
المساحات الخاليه التي هي جزء من عمليه
التنظيف التنظيم ولكن عندما نقوم بايضا
مشاهده الطوابق الاخرى في الدور الثاني
وكذلك الثالث وايضا على سطح المسجد نشاهد
ايضا امتلاء
هذه الادوار والطوابق من المعتمرين
والزوار وايضا في حركه سلسه وتنظيم جيد من
قبل القوات امنوا الحج والعمره التي تقوم
مع رئاسه شؤون الحرمين في خطه تشغيليه
تنظيميه من اجل سهوله خروج ودخول
المعتمرين والزوار دون عمليه تدافع او
كذلك اصابتهم باي مكروه لا يوجد اي ايضا
في عمليات التي رصدت من قبل او التي قامت
بها وزاره الصحه وكذلك هيئه الهلال الاحمر
السعودي من قبل مع المعتمرين والزوار برصد
اي حالات سواء مرضيه او كذلك عرضيه سوى
مجرد بعض المعتمرين في فتره النهار الذين
كانوا يعانون من الارهاب ايضا هذه عيادات
متنقيه صور التي ترصدها كاميرا
تتحرك طبعا عبر مركبات
نعم مركبات عباره عن مركبات كهربائيه
وكذلك دراجات ناريه يتم التنقل فيها
بسهوله هذا الجزء الذي يشاهدوه قبل ان
انتقل الى عمليه
الوحدات الطبيه هذا الجزء الذي نشاهده
الان وترصده كاميرا العربيه هو جزء من
ايضا صحن او عفوا سطح المطاف الذي خصص فقط
للمعتمرين ونشاهد في الجزء الاخر ايضا
هناك من الجلوس من الزوار الذين قدموا وهم
يجلسون وكذلك يؤدون عبادتهم بكل تنظيم وفق
حركه امنيه ومتابعه امنيه من الجهات
الرسميه وكهذا احد الاشخاص الذي يقوم
بتوجيه ايضا من رجاله الامن الذي يقوم
بتوجيه المعتمرين الى المكان المخصص لهم
وكذلك عدم توقفهم في هذا المساله التي
نشراتنا اللاحقه هاني الصفيان شكرا جزيلا
لك وهذه المشاهد الجميله جدا